we know the disease is more severe among
seniors and a pop-up vaccination site
opened today
to make the vaccine more accessible to
those 70 and older our hector mejia has
more on this pilot program
from jerome mack middle school thank you
for
giving me the opportunity heavy that's
hot
for husband and wife victor and flo
rodriguez it's a huge sigh of relief to
finally get the first dose
of the covet 19 vaccine they've isolated
themselves throughout this painful
pandemic
leaders from the county city and
southern nevada health district invited
us for a tour
here seniors got the pfizer vaccine
inside the gym
at mack middle school officials
recommend checking the health district's
website regularly
for future pop-up locations which are by
appointment only
it was quite hard i felt good and more
relaxed that i had it
i didn't have a problem at all i went
online i just had a brand new
grandchild and so i'll be hoping to
travel to austin you know in the next
few months and
see her for the first time we've learned
a future site is in the works at the
mexican consulate in las vegas
to better reach the hispanic community
but any future pop-up location
would depend on supply currently the
health district is receiving between
twenty two thousand and twenty five
thousand weekly doses
legend pointed out that's still not
enough i'm very happy for this
this opportunity this is a terrible
terrible
tragedy that's happened to us and the
whole world
reporting in the east valley hector
mejia 8 news now
all right thanks hector a vaccination
site at the canyon springs high school
up in north las vegas is also rolling
along
that site opened last week with about
1500 vaccinations allotted per day
organizers say they were able to
vaccinate about 360 people
in less than an hour and a half today
city councilman scott black says so far
the operation has been running with
minimal wait
times when i pulled into the parking lot
at
8 20 8 30 the parking lot was full when
you see a full parking lot you think oh
no big line
walk through the doors into the
courtyard minimal line
walk in here it's moving fluidly and
smoothly i think it's a phenomenal
turnout
and a very smooth operation organizers
say they vaccinated about ten thousand
people so far if you would like to make
an appointment there
we have posted a link for you on
eightnewsnow.com